hello everyone and welcome to another
really exciting game from the US
Championship 2022 it is a Wonderland
versus Levon aronian and if you liked
yesterday's game between Anand and
darjun as it was an incredibly
complicated game you will also enjoy
this one plus it uh or it resembles a
game not resembles but to a certain
point it follows the game Paul Murphy
played 167 years ago so it's um a very
exciting stuff and now let's check it
out I Wonder has the white pieces and he
opens with E4 we have E5 by Lavon Knight
to have three Knights to C6 and now
striking in the center with Ponta D4 so
a nice Scotch game E Capture Sunday for
and now Bishop to C for going for the
scotch Gambit and now uh Bishop the C5
and here you can uh well there are a
couple of moves you you could consider
here C3 is the main move uh there are
even some ideas that B4 can be played
here even though it was never never
attempted it's my idea but here nice the
G5 the startup variation is What a
Wonder goes for and it's a very very old
line like I said it was present when
when Paul morphy played chess and it
goes after the F7 Pawn now the only good
way to defend it is to defend with
Knight to H6 which is what level one
does Knight captures on F7
Knight captures with Bishop captures
with check King captures and now the
possession of the bishop and C5 is what
makes the sacrifice an F7 possible so
it's not really a sacrifice Queen H5
check G6 and now Queen captures on C5
winning back the piece and now uh the
game reached the point that Alexander
Balfour Meek had against Paul morphy In
1855 so 167 years ago and Paul Murphy
played the D6 in this position it's a
very famous game where morphy harasses
the White Queen and Indian forces the
White Queen to go back to the starting
Square to D1 before he he ends the game
brilliantly uh I can't even show I'm
pretty sure I made the video on this
game I just have no idea how I named it
so if any of you know what it is uh feel
free to share with everyone so they can
check it out but even though uh I'm I
mean I'm pretty sure I made a video on
it but I'm going to show you the game
after we check out this original game so
here Pawn to 5 instead does not follow
morphy's advice of Ponte D6 and now we
have Pawn to C3 and this Pawn the C3 is
a new move in the position there have
been some attempts of castles
also Queen captures on D5 check has been
played e captures on D5 advancing the
pawn to E5 has been played but C3 is a
new move so now already as of move 10 we
have a completely new game so here we
have uh E Capture D captures on e4 by 11
and uh Liang just castles and now how do
you continue levonne has a deep pawn and
the knee pawn and they're they're
incredibly impressive imagine if you can
get something like D3 going uh I mean
what could go wrong the problem is the
king is on F7 the King has no pawns just
F3 I mean this will be a devastating
Bishop coming to H6 this is a very very
hard to play so Levon says all right
let's bring the Rook into the game you
can have one of those spawns see
captures on D4 Queen characters and D4
level one would be very happy with the
queen trade of course but a Wonder says
Nope Queen to G5 and now comes Knight to
B4 here it would be much safer to play
something like bishopter
uh F5 but Knights the B4 is incredibly
interesting because here Le'Veon wants
to play a knight to C2 to go after the
Rook on A1 and it doesn't seem like you
have all that many great moves here but
I won't replace Bishop to D2 and now you
realize that if you go for the Rook with
Knight to C2 Bishop C3 attacks the queen
guards F6 guards G7 uh you will not be
able to defend this position if Queen
here are guarding this Square then just
Queen H6 I mean it's a completely
completely uh disgusting to defend this
with black and especially if you capture
the Rogue Ninja's Queen captures on H7
King E6 and now let's say Knight the A3
uh there's no escaping with the King all
of the squares here are being covered
Rook is coming to D1 at some point I
mean uh terrible so after Bishop to d211
says all right the knights the B4 might
not be such a great idea and he plays
Queen back to D6
uh and now what do you play uh here okay
you could try a lot of different ideas
but Aline just continues to develop
Knight to C3 C6 now the preventing the
knight from going any deeper and now
Rook 8 to D1 uh we have Bishop to F5 and
now there is
um uh well there is a way to break
through a Black's position here but you
have to be very very precise so feel
free to pause the video as Lavon is
already lost on move 16 uh while I give
you a couple of seconds and find the uh
the brilliant idea
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting either
of the two ideas one is F3 one is G4 F3
can be played simply to open up the f
file and well black would have to
capture here otherwise just captures
will win the game so let's say captures
captures and then G4 is coming there's
really not much you can do about this
but instead G4 was playing it's very
similar uh now adjust attacking the
bishop and there's really no good way uh
to to move the bishop here your Bishop
is hanging and if you play something
like Bishop to D7 uh then you put the
bishop in front of the Rook something
like let's say Knight B5 attacks the
queen and if C captures on B5 Bishop
captures on B4 and now you can't capture
because Rook captures on these seven
checks and um yeah you're just gonna get
destroyed so you can play some like
Queen E6 but now H3 and again uh it's
not much not much of a material
advantage but the blacking is wide open
on F7 uh you will not be able to hold
this so instead level one finds is a
very tricky idea he plays H6 offers the
H6 Pawn but of course for the moment the
pawn cannot be captured if you capture
Rook to h8 and now Levon is the one who
is in trouble and you have to play some
very very precise moves here to to get
out of this like Knight captures you
attack the black queen after Bishop
captures now you can play Bishop
captures attack the black queen again
and as the black queen moves to keep an
eye on the H2 Pawn now he played Bishop
to D6 and now you force a queen Trace
I'm like captures captures in Bishop D5
you would get uh to play this end game
but of course you do not want to throw
away all of your advantage so Liang just
goes Queen back to H4
and now the bishop is still hanging the
problem is and this is why G4 is so
strong and no doubt why all of you found
it when you pause the video Bishop to E6
loses Bishop to D7 loses and Bishop to
C8 loses and Levon played Bishop to C8
but it's such an ugly move that I feel
that it is necessary to discuss why
Bishop to E6 is bad well okay Rook no
longer guards D for Pawn just Knight
captures attacks the queen gains access
to all of these squares Bishop now can
come to C3 uh this is pretty much
self-explanatory now the other idea
after uh uh uh for example the retreat
with the bishop to D7 is now that not
only the queen is a target here but also
the bishop and now you can play Bishop
captures on H6 and after a move like
Knight to D5 blocking the rook's attack
towards the queen now you play F3 and
after E3 keeping the f file closed now
Knight to E4 again attacking the Queen
Once the queen moves because you have to
keep an eye on this Square I otherwise
just captures in the queen to F6 you can
play Rook after E1 and after Rook the h8
putting the Rook here now even Rook
captures on E3 and there is not much you
can do row captures runs into Rook
captures on D7 and now if Queen to F4
which is a very tricky idea as it seems
like you're offering the queen but white
can even trade here Bishop capture
through captures and after Bishop G5
Rook H back to h8 and now Knights the D6
check for example King to G8 and uh as
The Rook is hanging Rook D to suit gets
some sort of a position like this
where it's very unpleasant for black to
play Rook to fade you can defend the
pawn with King to G2 and you get
something like this with white having
two fully active Rooks the bishop is
beautiful on G5 H4 is coming the Knight
is spectacular on D6 and the black Rooks
not really doing all that much the
Knight and the bishop are in um well on
a pretty bad Square so this would be uh
winning for wine so those are the two
options and also one of the reasons why
why Lebon after G4 played the bishop all
the way back to C8 but now even though
there aren't any tactics against the
bishop itself the Rooks are no longer
connected and therefore you don't have
to fear Rook to h8 so now uh Ling just
captures an H6 and okay the queen is now
hanging so Knights the D3 and now Bishop
to G5 preparing Queen to H7 check so
Queen to E5 preparing to go back with
the queen if check is delivered and now
uh Pawn to F3 just uh hoping to open up
the f file and there's really no good
way to
um to counter this you can't really
capture or push the pawn because then
the Knight hangs so you have to just
wait and hope for the best here Rook to
h8 is played as the queen also covers
the h8 square now F captures an E4 opens
up a discovery here King to G8 now
Bishop to H6 is beautiful uh prevents uh
Rook capture screen but also threatens
The Rook to f8 to check so Queen to D
for checking the H1 and now Bishop to E6
again connecting the Rooks not really as
the king is in G8 but sort of connecting
everything and now Queen to G5 preparing
Queen captures on G6 so Bishop to F7 and
now of course you're not gonna allow
levanta
set up some some sort of a defense here
just to Rook captures on F7 and now if
King captures uh then Rook the F1 check
and you just go on a nice King Khan even
if Knight to F2 check you can just play
King G2 and still you're gonna capture
this Knight if King D6 you try and run
away Rook captures and after Rook 8 to
G8 regarding that g Pawn you can even
play E5 and that's just it there's um
there there's no move you can play here
Knight covers d square so no checks are
possible uh if Queen captures then
rookie 2 just captures the queen
um that it resigns so what uh you have
to play here after all captures on F7
well you have to resign but of course
level one will try a few more tricks
Rook captures on H6 is what he played
now Rook captures on D3 it's not
mandatory you could also play other
moves but it just eliminates any any uh
counter chances Levon might have Queen
characters on D3 and now of course not
Queen captures on H6 and allowing King
captures here but a nice Queen to F6 now
threat happening Checkmate here so can
Lavon defend this uh the problem is
um there's no way to check the the white
king the B1 Square covered by the Knight
discovered by the Knight discovered by
the queen discovered by the queen and
those are basically the four squares
that the black queen can use uh to check
the white king and also this is defended
by the knight uh so there are no checks
here Levon has to give up The Rook uh in
order to
uh try and get some sort of a Perpetual
there is the maybe interesting uh uh
instead of just going for real captures
on H2 right away
you could try some checks but it's very
hard to
to actually do them uh as they're not
possible yet so first you have to play
Rook captures in H2 King captures with
Queen to D2 checking to G1 and now Queen
to C1 with check King to F2 and now uh
Queen to H6 stopping Checkmate the
reason why not Queen captures and beat
you is uh very very interesting but we
have to show it now you're not gonna
move the Knight and allow the trade of
Queens you're gonna play King E3 now
look at this queen C1 check King to D3
you even allow Rook to d8 check because
now if Queen captures Rook then King
captures rook and F7 now King the C for
you even allow B5 with check you move
the king to B3 and now there are no more
checks and of course you are getting
checkmated once Queen H6 is played G5
comes and that's just it the queen has
doesn't have access to these squares and
of course once you want the queen you
get checkmated so after King to F2 Queen
to H6 was played right away without
going for all of that but now Pawn to G5
and it was in this position on move 32
that Levon Aryan resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
very nicely done once the queen moves of
course Checkmate is coming so
beautifully played by by a wonder and
for those of you who are interested I
will now show uh how the game went from
that position uh in the game between
um between meek and Paul Murphy and for
those of you who are interested uh
leading the tournament now is Fabiana
corvana with three and a half points and
the Wonderland and Samuel Savion are
tied in second and third with with three
points but now let's go back to this
position and I have to let let Meadow in
the room uh I can hear him coming
foreign
there's some food being cooked down
there so Meadow is uh you know uh
watching if everything is prepared
properly but yeah after Queen captures
on c511 played the D5 here against the
Wonder but uh morphy played the D6
against Meek and now let's just quickly
go over that game as it's quite a nice
one so now the queen is already hanging
we have Queen the B5 and now Rook the E8
morphe of course goes for the white king
queen the B3 with check and now only Now
Pawn to D5 by morphe but now of course
uh opening up the E file is not
something you want to do so Pawn to F3
defending and not Knight the A5 morphe
further continues harassing the White
Queen Queen to D3 here Queen to B5
repeating would be would be slightly
better and then if C6 then you can bring
the queen to E2 but okay migplate Queen
to D3 and now morphy captures an e for
which tempo as the queen is hanging F
captures an E4 and now Queen the H4 with
check G3 Rook captures an E4 with check
King to F2 and queen to E7 now preparing
to bring the bishop into the game and
land that rook and f8 so here Knight the
D2 was played attacking The Rook but now
Rook the E3 as Bishop no longer covers
this Square Queen to B5 going after the
Knight but morphino says come on are you
serious he plays C6 and he offers up the
Knight but the Knight of course cannot
be captured as the queen must have
guarded the E2 Square so Queen back to
F1 and now the beautiful Bishop to H3
again morphe offers the bishop to free
up D2 square if you capture then Rook
the E to check will just end in a very
very nice Checkmate Queen to E3 with
checking G4 H5 with the check and that's
it now you either give up the queen or
King stage four and queen to E7 will be
Checkmate so instead of all of this
after Bishop to H3 uh morphe forces mix
Queen all the way way back to the
starting Square king queen queen to D1
and now it's a a matter of rooked Fate
this is what morphe played uh and he was
in this position on move 20 that
Alexander Mick resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
actually maybe it's not in this position
that he resigned I'm pretty sure it's in
this position but I will check I don't
want to trick you guys let me just check
ah no okay so it's not in this position
Knight to F3 was played uh preparing to
sort of kind of block check but the Dan
Murphy played King to E8 and it was in
this position that um Alexander Mick
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here problem is uh well
I mean problem is look at your position
uh let's say Rook to E1 now will offer a
trade of uh Rooks here and maybe remove
some of the attackers the problem is you
can just play Rook captures on F3 and
remove the all of the Defenders Of The
Rook on E1 let's say queen captures an
F3 Rook campers and F3 King captures now
Queen captures anyone and uh that's
pretty much it nothing much to be done
here whatever you play let's say B4 it's
a matter of a few checks before you get
checkmated Queen D5 and that's it all of
the squares are taken from the uh from
the white king if G4 G5 checking G3 and
queen G2 for example will be Checkmate
but of course Miki did not wait for all
of this once morphe played King back
back to E8 it was in this position that
he resigned in the game but what what is
incredible about this game is that uh
mixed sacrifices the sort of uh harassed
the amorphous King and forced the king
away from the starting square and then
the queen of course jumps into the
attack but then morphy forces the White
Queen all the way back to her starting
Square while he brings his King all the
way to his starting Square so it's not
only an in an impressive game and a very
precise game but also a very very poetic
one uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys you know those were the games hope
you guys enjoyed that never ever
doubtful morphe and the good things will
happen to you I would like to thank red
rose Kerrigan David Masa Matthew Benoit
and ravishing reptiles YouTube for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
and thank all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
everything that's currently happening in
the Chess World and checking up on your
wonderful suggestions uh so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day